foreign
[Music]
this is Far and Away the most dangerous
thing we've ever attempted
we've been working on this for years
we're going to shoot it in Norway and
it'll be a motorcycle jump off a cliff
into a base jump
I want to do it since I was a little kid
it all comes down to one thing
the audience
there's a lot going into this stunt so
Tom put together this master plan to
coordinate all of these experts in each
of the particular disciplines involved
to make this whole thing happen John and
I are jumping out of the helicopter he's
gonna chase me unless we say to each
other don't be careful to be confident
be confident
a year of Base training Advanced Skydive
training a lot of canopy skills a lot of
tracking Tom Cruise these amazing
individuals you tell them something and
he just locks it in his sense of spatial
awareness he's the most aware person
I've ever met
lots of practice on stability and Free
Fall trekking with John and miles in the
air doing lots of different positioning
like there were two men team in the air
coming on top of each other below each
other backtracking front tracking you
know we've drilled and drilled and
drilled
when you do a lot of jumps back to back
the canopy control skills improve a lot
we have three open canopies which is a
good thing the training's gone really
well it's a progressive massive views
thank you how are you great day man this
is the next part of training right here
at the Motocross let's do it
so we built a motocross track
getting comps in the Motocross so he's
comfortably jumping 70 80 foot table
tops great time in the air great
positioning on the bike Landing world I
have to get so good at this that there's
just no way that I miss my marks that's
good come a little closer to me coming
up with the stunt is only one of the
technical challenges the other is
putting a camera in a place that you can
see where Tom is doing it finding the
right lens the right platform the right
medium even two years ago the cameras
didn't exist that would allow us to do
what we're trying to do today how do we
involve the audience I just want to give
them that thrill that means the camera
has to be in front of Tom and as close
to him as possible feels like you're
going over the camera yes very cool
[Music]
train and drill every little aspect over
and over and over and over again they
were doing 30 jumps a day getting to a
point where he was just a machine I mean
over 500 skydives
that's what we do over 13 000 Motocross
jumps
all right it's gonna be fun oh it's
great
replicated this ramp in England at a
quarry we filled the Quarry with
cardboard boxes which were there to
catch the motorcycle the reason why we
did that is so that Tom could simulate
the jungle how fast should I go off what
distance do I travel
built models of different ramps at
different angles to calculate what Tom's
trajectory would be we have to be able
to consistently predict where Tom is
going to be in three-dimensional space
we're going to have a GPS chip on me and
that recorded every single one of Tom's
jumps along with his ground speed
whether there was a headwind whether
there was a crosswind and by doing this
multiple times we were able to get a
consistent set of data so that each take
we can see what height I am so this way
we can set drones and cameras into
places where I can go right into closer
rule one don't hit me
because if we do it all we don't capture
it right what's the point let's do it
guys ready yep always grab my earplugs
so I don't hear myself scream
we are already ready
the key is me hitting certain speeds and
being consistent with that there's no
speedometer so I do it by sound and feel
of the bike
and then as I depart the bike I'm using
the wind that's hitting me here and I'm
cupping my chest that will give me lifts
[Music]
you all very much for your help guys
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
Norway
we've been constructing this ramp over a
number of months everything here has to
be brought in by helicopter engineers
and technicians it's incredible what
they've done this is masterful today is
day one of principal photography and we
are starting in classic mission Forum
with the biggest stunt in the film what
we're doing here is I'm just doing jumps
just to warm up the body let's do it
just to get my tracking going and make
sure everything's working all right
try not to smile
basically when he gets down and puts a
parachute around and goes and does the
bike job he'll actually know the weather
conditions in this area in the valley
and on the ground
[Music]
and then he has to see if we deploy the
parachute
now he's in a rock ball with walls all
around him and he's got to fly out of it
of course you know when something's been
done for the first time you can't help
but worry a little bit about how it's
really going to turn out with a jump
like this the challenge is finding the
cameras it's the amount of preparation
and then it's weather you want the light
to be right you want the clouds to be
right Misty but not foggy this weather
right here is exactly what we're looking
for she is about 10 minutes away from
coming up here landing and doing the
actual class sounds good we're in motion
see you soon now we're going to set the
frames of this camera ship with the
Drone just to verify everything that
we're gonna get ready
you know the only things you really have
to avoid while doing a stunt like this
is a serious injury or death here we go
you're riding a motorcycle which is
pretty dangerous on top of a ramp that's
elevated off the ground so if you come
off the ramp that's going to be very bad
you're falling if you don't get a clean
exit from the bike and you get tangled
up with it if you don't open your
parachute then you're not going to make
it
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks mate I think I can hold to the
bike a little longer
[Music]
pretty much the biggest stunt in cinema
history
Tom Cruise just rode a motorcycle off a
cliff six times today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Far and Away the most dangerous thing
we've ever attempted
the only thing that scares me more is
what we have planned for mission 8.